[Music]
in making a change news submitted by
love from from I like making a
difference except for like things that
go bad because the difference true
Oxford University has introduced a
mandatory exam on ethnic minority
history to diversify its overly black
curriculum where's Oliver University is
that in the England I think that
University is older than either the
Aztec or the Mayan Empire one of those
yeah yeah and it's older than the
temples whether it's like the Mexican
pyramids or something like that that's
crazy huh fun fact
so Oxford University so I gather
introducing these exams to their
students to their history students
undergraduate history history students
so before they were only required to
take two papers on British history and
two on European history and so last year
there was a lot of protests saying like
there was like this campaign going
around saying like why is my curriculum
white like so white so then that's when
the school now has sort of responded to
that in a way let me just play hip-hop
in the class keep up with you - history
of minority mmm-hmm hip-hop and then you
write English papers down the top and
karate yeah BAM yeah that's all I kept
EE hip hop in the classroom and then
Mexican soup for lunch
yep oh yeah I understand US universities
because we are a nation of immigrants
and a lot of non lakh people contributed
a whole lot to this country but I'm not
too sure about like British history I
know that they one time controlled a lot
of countries and they exported the [ __ ]
out of non-white people but then I don't
know like I don't know anything about
their history are they trying to
reference like black people or Indian
people or anything exactly those - it's
like notable British
Jasser example rockin Indians and uh
like feel and Britain yeah kiss my
elbows oh great you know that's all okay
yeah so did the others they're saying
that potential topics would include like
Martin Luther King jr. but he's not
British he does after erudition black
history
oh yeah and like the 1960 civil rights
movement and like um like Gandhi and
Indian independence that's British yeah
no I'm just thinking like we don't learn
about non US history themes even if it's
multicultural it's all US history stuff
but University that looks different
depends on the major I think yeah I
think maybe for them this is notable
points in history so I didn't want to
Luther King wasn't just fighting for
civil rights in America's for the world
let in the world history yeah
well or not world and so it's important
uh so they never had this [ __ ] before
never they're screwing the mandatory I
to make it a mandatory part of the
curriculum in order for you to graduate
was like it was a history major they've
never had other ethnicities like history
to be so they were just studying like
eggs benedict all-time what's it what's
a notable who's a notable like British
person Winston Churchill I know him he
like to cigars all the time and also
James Bond oh I like the old ones I am
not the not the new one the old one had
class mmm the new one doesn't why like
Sean Connery oh yeah Sean Connery old
old old so old when he was young
we don't know jack-shit about British
power oh yeah I know
the be adults the be addled beatless
all I know is for us history everything
that they taught us about the British
were bad guys the Redcoats are coming
the Redcoats are coming that's the bad
people so I don't know anything about
them I just thought there were just all
white people wearing the Quaker Oatmeal
yeah and they brought slaves to the US
that's that's all I know they did all
the bad stuff really I'm surprised you
to join history but you know no more I
just know the old stuff like the Game of
Thrones stuff
thank you know like Lannister always
repay their debt yep yeah like I don't
go fast like that yeah yeah but I don't
know you guys have thoughts on the fact
that there's versifying I think it's
guilt that it's the white people or the
non-whites that are complaining about
this I mean is it like the white people
that are like hey our stuff is white
centric or is it black and Indian
students that are like hey this is too
flat well they have a majority of white
students they're saying that beckham's
2014 Oxford only had 27 black students
and like the entire school so yeah the
majority of the students are wanting to
be white and that's why there was a
campaign you know about them complaining
the boys my trick is white but yeah
there was also a lot of protests because
they wanted to remove a statue of a
Victorian imperialist named Cecil Rhodes
and that like those entire protests
trying to get rid of a statute like
because of what he represents and all
that stuff and so that's why the college
is saying or the University of saying
we're not changing our curriculum
because of those protests but it just
seemed like it was time to change our
curriculum but they are part of the
process they didn't do any
um what they did they didn't do any
history that's called multicultural
history yeah that's what they're sent
LLB that's what she's saying she's
saying mandatory yeah mandatory so they
probably had electives for all these
other histories history classes but to
make it mandatory I think it should be
mandatory so I think like in u.s.
curriculum I think world history is
mandatory as a prereq that's why they're
teen yards that's evident what is my
mind that be yes they barely got to it
and this is one of the most renowned
schools it's like imagine like MIT was
like finally we will be teaching
sure I don't know something something
that's like we're kind of like Harvard
saying finally we will we will be
studying
Martin Martin Luther King yeah it's like
what's exactly you haven't been studying
him yet
yeah that's what blows my mind if I were
ya cuz you know what's crazy though is
that here in the US people had to like
get into fights and riots to get the
multicultural like electives in so the
Asian American Studies Department
African American Studies Department
Gender Studies on all these whatever it
all started in Berkeley and they
petitioned the cultural clubs petitioned
the administration to get it in but they
wouldn't sit in a protest and then the
protest turned into the cops just coming
in and being the [ __ ] out of the
students and then the students kind of
locked down and it turned into all-out
war Wow
crazy stories back there man in the 60s
yeah I watched a documentary it was
about the Black Panthers and there was
agents inside the Black Panthers alright
yeah and another crazy thing is in
California we're kind of spoiled because
we go we go through high school learning
about you know our culture's
contribution to this nation so we feel
like Hello American right but in the
Midwest East Coast South they don't
teach anything about Asian American
Studies they don't no one knows that
we're actually a part of this country
and we helped out like for a long time
we've been doing a lot of [ __ ] here guys
we've been here for a while but no one
knows that's true because we learned
about that like Chinese built railroads
and there's a recent 18 minutes yeah but
no one else knows so when I go to the
Midwest ago they still call me mr. king
I'd rather be called mr. railroad your
father your way longer than their sound
yeah even even Chicano Studies and stuff
you know like Cesar Chavez not the salad
but they don't even want to see the
challenge salad yes they don't learn
about the Cesar Chavez salad with the
chicken
yes they don't they don't nobody knows
nothing so it's interesting even within
the states they don't [ __ ] teach that
[ __ ] maybe if they actually taught that
there would be way more unity maybe
that's why they don't want that [ __ ]
that the curriculum is so region centric
then we're missing out a lot of good
stuff that we don't know about like I
don't know I barely know anything about
Louisiana and I didn't find out that
Louisiana had a huge French influence
until you guys went for the first time
investor telling me like there's so much
French influence in the cuisine and all
that stuff and it's supposed to be like
Cajun makes the French food on the Oh
what see I just I wish I would have
known I thought sure because Casey
mentioned I came growing up like he only
learned about history like in the
southwest and I loved it yeah like only
like Texas history you didn't really
didn't teach him much about what we left
rkg the only smoked Marlboro he doesn't
yeah let me ride horses yeah all my arm
Asian friends that I knew like in the
Boston or like my roommate Kevin he's
from Boston he said growing up he didn't
know nothing about like Asian American
Studies they don't study that [ __ ] in
Boston we've been here for a long time
for centuries I don't even know if this
country's existed a long but wait that's
1700 I remember reading about Asian
people in Hawaii that were like doing
the sugarcane stuff harvesting sugarcane
I think the west coast and Hawaii is the
only places that teach that curriculum
of the minority helping that's not where
we were not United that's why that's
true huh so maybe we have to change like
the curriculum or something you know we
should petition all the elementary
schools should learn about what every
single ethnic group did to contribute
yeah to the Americans I want to learn
about how the Portuguese people brought
us the bread I want to learn about how
Italians brought us the Goodfellas yeah
I want to learn all that I want to learn
how you know like the Vietnamese people
everybody has nail salons yeah every
nail salon all over the country is owned
by a Vietnamese person
and in the Cambodians at the donut shops
yep no no no stuff yep
yeah and how the hell did Chinese
restaurants find their way in a little
town in Colorado everywhere they'll even
speak English hello a lot of people do
you want to contact me and everybody
else you see go ahead and check the
description box below and follow our
social medias is the Grahams and
Twitter's for more videos click up there
baby